hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game featuring a very interesting
opening that i played a few days ago i
thought about showing it on the channel
but never really had uh
any spare moments but now i was kind of
waiting to show you the wesley versus
hikaru game but they decided to go for
the famous um berlin draw after only a
few moves so we're not going to be
showing that and the first game from
defeated grand prix finals i didn't uh i
i didn't consider it to be all that
interesting so i decided to skip it and
maybe show the second game but the
second game was this um uh well uh draw
that we've seen uh far too many times so
i decided okay this would be maybe a
nice opportunity to show you at this
game
and maybe get more of you to try using
the evans gambit in your online
adventures so uh we're going to be
checking it out i have the white pieces
my opponent is a gentleman named bar 555
he was rated around 2300 when the game
was played now i will put a link of the
actual game in the description below so
if you want to check it out you are
welcome to do so because we are not
going to show the entire game the entire
game is very long uh as
i had a really stupid moment and then i
blundered all of my advantage i still
was able to win the game as i employed
some dirty flagging techniques and
that's why i won
but the the beginning of the game is
quite nice so we are going to focus on
that but if you want you can check out
the entire game in the description so i
had the white pieces and i opened with
e4 as i usually do my opponent played e5
knight to f3 knight to c6 and the bishop
to c4 i go for the italian game of
course hoping my opponent goes for
bishop to c5 which he does and i was
very happy here as i get to play the
evans gambit so b4 i offer a pawn for
some very nice um expansion we have
bishop captures on b4 he accepts the
gambit and now c3 you know we've said
many times and i even made a short video
on this that the bishop can retreat to
many different squares and you should
pretty much know all of them if you
still haven't seen it do check it out it
will be the first link in the
description below but uh in this game
bishop to a5 was played which is a very
very nice i strike in the center with
the d4 e capture sunday for and now
queen to b3 uh here castles is the most
popular option but queen to b3 second
most popular i prefer this one
as uh for those uh who who are not um uh
so uh
often uh well uh attacked by the evans
gambit maybe maybe uh
who will not be able to defend against
queen to b3 all that well and this is a
three-minute blitz game so that's what i
was going for queen to e7 he has to
defend the f7 uh pawn and i just castle
here and here you should always go for
bishop to b6 this is black's main
defensive idea against this line of the
evans gambit point is you free up the a5
square for the knight you want to play
knight a5 and eliminate the light square
bishop so that's uh as this will be a
huge problem for black and many lines
but my opponent played d6 and okay this
is still perfectly fine uh if you know
what you're doing but uh it seems that
the position is already incredibly
incredibly sharp i played bishop to a3
here i prepared this e5 idea as it makes
sense the d6 pawn is pinned so of course
i want to open up this and a knight to
f6 will be met with e5 uh but uh even
even more interesting is e5 right away
so the the idea why this is so strong
is that if for example d captures an e5
is played we can simply play c captures
on d4 and now after e captures on v4 it
seems like you don't really have
anything because rook to a1 is
impossible both queen and
the bishop are covering the the e1
square but there is this knight to d2
move which makes black's position really
really uncomfortable rook to e1 is now
coming also bishop to a3 and the next
move depending on what black plays this
will be very very hard
almost impossible to defend for black
and another thing after e5 you don't
have to capture of course with the deep
one you could capture with the knight
here but then we capture with our own
knight now black has to recapture this
and you have to be careful otherwise
bishop to b5 check will also queen to b5
check will also win the bishop on a5 so
here queen captures has to be played to
guard the bishop but now we pick up the
f7 pawn bishop captures king f8 and now
c captures on d4 this is just a very
very ugly position to be in but still
it's playable for black for example
queen f5 we're going to attack the
bishop bishop moves back and we continue
black is still up material uh he lost
castling privileges and he will of
course go knight to f6 next and try to
somehow get his pieces into the game but
it is very nice and seemingly after d6
e5 is the way to go but okay i played
bishop to a3 uh my opponent played
bishop to b6 now he wants to play knight
to the a5 here and i played c characters
on d4 sort of trying to get him to maybe
consider capturing on d4 because of
course now okay he can play knight to 85
but then i keep the strong center uh and
here he played knight captures on d4 now
knight the a5 is still uh preferred here
but he he went for the pawn which is
still okay and nothing wrong with this
uh knight captures and b for bishop
captures and now i play knight to c3
and in many similar lines of the evince
gambit uh you will have this idea of
going to d5 with your knight and my
opponent did not want to allow this
especially now when the queen is on e7
and he stopped this by playing c6 and c6
is a terrible mistake here if you want
to stop this you have to play knight to
f6 then okay you guard the d5 square
next move you're gonna castle and the
game continues however here after c6 the
game is now uh well just winning for
white and you have to find the correct
idea i played rook a to d1 this is the
correct idea i attacked the bishop and
now if the bishop moves we're of course
going to capture on d6 so you could
block this with bishop to c5 sorry
bishop to c5 or bishop to e5 but bishop
to e5 looks pretty silly after f4
black has to go for bishop captures in
c3 and now we capture on d6 first to go
for a nice in-between move queen f6 and
now even bishop to e5 in black
completely falls apart here bishop
captures let's say f captures here and
now look at this uh black is
just falling apart here the rook also
controls the d file uh not much for for
black to do here
uh so instead after rook eight to d1 my
opponent didn't go bishop t5 he played
bishop to c5
but now of course the game is completely
winning for white uh so feel free to
pause the video and to win the game for
me
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this wild
idea and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is of course pawn
to e5 we have to open up the center at
any cost as the queen and king are
nicely aligned on the e file and this is
what we're going to use so my opponent
played bishop captures on a3 but i do
not recapture i just play e captures on
d6 now attacking his queen and he played
bishop captures on these six backs so he
won a piece now but i have rook f to e1
and now how do you defend against this
well if you go bishop to e6 we just
capture it and there's really not all
that much now you're gonna move the
bishop and still the rook will be
extremely strong here uh even there are
some lines even if you move the king we
can even play rook captures um on d6 for
example queen captures on d6 and queen
captures on b7 now threatening the rook
and also threatening checkmate so black
is uh
completely lost here if he plays bishop
to e6 so here bishop to e5 was played
and okay now you don't have such ideas
but you have something else uh bishop
captures an f7 i could also play f4 but
i thought that this would be stronger
and okay the engine agrees so bishop
captures an f7 is fine uh king to f8 uh
if you go for queen captures on f7 then
we just play rook captures and e5 with
check so my opponent didn't want to
allow this he played king to f8 but i
still played rook captures on e5 with
check and now the point is
if queen captures on e5 we just play
rook to d8 with check and after king to
e7 we play rook to e8 to check pick up
the queen and that's it uh you don't
even get to uh win the rook with the
king because there's knight to e for
check first and now there's really
nothing better if king f5 you're gonna
get checkmated so you're gonna have to
give up the queen this way
so instead after rook captures on e5 my
opponent was still very resourceful he
played bishop to g4 now attacked my rook
on d1 and here
uh what uh what to do play i played rook
captures on e7 it's a perfectly fine
move uh grabbing the queen because the
game is completely winning for white now
but even stronger would have been rook d
to e1 it's okay maybe a bit weird in a
in a three-minute blitz game to allow
your opponents to move the queen when
you could just grab it but here there's
just no move for black and it's such a
beautiful position uh
if you capture the bishop just queen
before check
black king has no squares you have to
put something in between just rook
captures on e7 attack the queen once the
queen moves you have all sorts of nasty
discoveries so this is um uh completely
winning but okay i played rook captures
on e7 uh he played bishop capture sunday
one attacked my queen and now pretty
much any move here in this position is
winning
uh you could just for example capture
the bishop here and after uh he captures
the rook we can just play queen to f3
and there's no move black can make any
move uh well you're gonna have to give
up the knight because you have to free
up this square for the king otherwise uh
we just move the king and play queen to
f7 so you're gonna have to play
something like knight g6 and then we
capture this with check and now it's
completely unplayable however i played
queen to b4 i actually forgot that the
knight covers the e7 square and now the
game takes a bit of a different turn but
still after knight captures on e7 which
he captured i have to play queen to f4
and it's still completely winning for me
because the idea is the same we're going
to move the bishop and the the black
king has no squares but i played knight
captures on d1 he played king captures
on f7 and now the game is not so great i
played queen captures on b7 and the
engine gives this as roughly equal
and
well i i have to i have to agree with
the engine because i simply could not
find any any useful moves here so in the
end the game lasted for some this is
move 22 the game lasted for 22 more
moves and in the end i won the game by
dirty flagging my opponent which is not
very honorable but i was very sad that i
blundered such a beautiful uh
winning position and then i i didn't
want to lose rating as well uh so that's
why i did it but um
yeah other than that it was a it was a
fine evans gambit game and
you know
it's still possible to blunder it
doesn't matter how good your position is
uh here after even after i didn't go for
this best rook rook dte1 uh my opponent
uh played bishop captures and d1 like
literally any move uh any move is
perfectly winning here i could even
capture on b7 i could do really i mean
there's uh but queen before uh
i completely forgot the the knight could
just capture the rook here and it's
still uh probably winning for white but
um you know any other move would have
one uh but yeah basically i'm showing
you this game and making this video to
show you how it's very much possible to
get great positions with yemen's gambit
and that still not a lot of people uh
know how to defend against it because
there are a couple of lines that are
really really good for black and if
the player with the black pieces knows
them then you're going to have a very
interesting game uh you know to say the
least but if uh
if you don't know for example the ideas
of bishop to b6 when they have to be
played exactly then you're going to have
a very very uh easy uh
easy game with white especially in the
opening and if you like attacking if you
like open games then you're gonna enjoy
it very much
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it do use the evans gambit and
especially when you get to that critical
point uh don't blunder the game like i
did uh but rather you know i
ended the game like like it should end
by you winning the game brilliantly uh
but if you don't then you can also like
me use some dirty flagging techniques
and flag your opponent uh
yeah i mean it's it's not the best but
uh
yeah
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank hop
and sheep edmund freeman uh christian
jannot uh and the murderers gambit for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it uh as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the video grand prix uh
unless they uh continue making these uh
quick draws but yeah i hope that doesn't
happen and if you guys still haven't do
check out the evans gambit tutorial
video it will be the first link in the
description below so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day